I've never known a guy more talented at
untangling politics so that anyone can
understand very heart is being bold and
inventive ideas into American politics
it is a gift and he wants to share that
with people
Bart is pushing groundbreaking reforms
and education and foreign policy I want
you to think about the opportunity that
we have right now with the ideas and
vision to take America into the 21st
century
and the cost to this great country if we
squander it about America's future ideas
have powerful ideas of what this
election is all about balance no heart
beating bush baseball like 12 Gary Hart
is considered the man to beat
[Applause]
ask your question
do you feel like you have a traditional
marriage there is no privacy the cameras
go everywhere the one thing I ever asked
this don't embarrass me
Center get sex with that woman can be
scary there's no need for that don't you
think you owe it to us to be for us oh
you you're running for president I'm a
word that comments in the paper
do you have a responsibility czar dunno
yours
there are stories being written right
now there is no story
women izing lies just because some other
paper use gossip is front-page news and
that doesn't mean we have it says now
this campaign is about the future not
rumors not sleaze
care about the sanctity of this process
whether you do or do not
[Music]
in a matter of days hearts campaign has
collapsed we're talking about how you
get through today
without pissing away everything we've
all worked for on this campaign
we use this we can kiss the white house
goodbye
[Music]
you